[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
today marks the biggest update to hit
Battle Royale since its inception just
over 100 days ago I've delved into the
two point two points on patch notes and
have found 20 things I think you should
know of course we don't just tell you
the news we show you the difference the
update brings you ready let's do this
let's start with the most obvious the
biggest additions are the five new named
areas on the map junk Junction haunted
hills snobby shores shifty shafts and
the humongous tilted towers but these
aren't the only new additions north of
flush factory are a few new areas and
all over the maps likes changes to
abandoned buildings and solitary
settlements have been brought in in the
coming weeks I'll be looking for all
those brand spanking new loot chests and
more importantly I'll be bringing videos
to help you with Luke runs for easier
victories but for now let's have a look
at what else has changed in patch two
point 2.0 the sculpt AR may be dead to a
great deal of us but this under loved
Beauty has received an upgraded
crosshair when aiming down the sights
the new scope definitely improved target
position but I don't know if it's enough
to warrant taking one with you
additionally scoped a ARS will no longer
be found in air drops hallelujah this
should make those balloon drops highly
desirable once again the snowball
launcher and all the Christmas trees
lovely gifts underneath have now gone
and the original grenade launcher has
returned there are some great
improvements to life in Battle Royale
which may seem inconsequential but
believe me they will make a difference
for example it is now possible to
continue aiming your weapon after
jumping from Heights no longer will you
be forced to release and reapply the aim
button has this ever happened to you
well that shouldn't happen anymore as
loot will no longer land in the same
space as the chest
similarly if you've ever tried to Reza's
teammate but repeatedly found yourself
picking up loot next to their dining
corpse and fear no more this has been
rectified building has been slightly
improved to streetlights and chests no
longer prevent you from building over
the top this maid fights in Pleasant
Park and greasy Grove a little bit
difficult at times
friendly fire has now been disabled so
team killing Walt happens for at least a
few weeks this is a great time to learn
how to rock it right as you want to each
other to smithereens so give it a go
have you noticed it's quite difficult to
shoot someone in water well water will
no longer prevent bullet penetration so
this means kills at loot Lake should be
little less frustrating speaking of
water new animations have been added and
the ability to look under water has been
removed here's a really cool new
addition sniper kills will now display
the distance the shot was taken from so
I'm expecting my twitter feed to be
filled with screenshots of ridiculous
kill distances speaking of distance the
terribly low res far distances you've
seen down your sniper barrel will be
somewhat improved with this update maybe
just maybe that slice of toast in the
distance is real and not a mirage The
Weekly star will now update twice a week
and include more vanity items than ever
epic are cashing in on our desire to
stand out from the crowd so stock up on
the books
dusty Depot now has additional
ammo crates to plunder another huge
update comes in the shape of resources
and those shipping containers they yield
far more metal than they once did before
the update we received 27 metal for our
workload and now we receive 25 okay so
maybe this is still a bit hit-and-miss
I tried different containers and some
gave up 247 maybe we should keep an eye
on this one so expect more action at
this location in the future low times on
console and PC have been improved
remarkably we are told ps4 and Xbox have
twice the speed of past updates this
optimisation should improve things
across the board most noticeably those
texture pop-in should be a little less
noticeable the frustrating bug which
makes your own footsteps echo or double
up has been removed so now you don't
have to be scared of your own footsteps
another bug which has finally been
removed is the bullet whizzing noises
which happen unexpectedly and frighten
the [ __ ] out of all of us and personally
my favorite the cartoony world has
received new grass and foliage to frolic
through I know it means nothing to you
but I bloody well love it thank you epic
games so there you go 20 updates brought
in in patch 2 point 2.0 fortnight is
going from strength to strength I'll be
back very soon with new loot runs and
more Battle Royale
action I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time